so our headlines begin with another
alleged attack by an alleged white
supremacist NBC News has the report the
driver of a truck that crashed into
security barriers near the White House
on Monday night has been identified as a
19 year old from Missouri who was
arrested on multiple charges including
threatening to kill or harm a president
vice president or family member
officials said authorities said the
preliminary investigation indicates that
the driver intentionally crashed into
the bollards outside of Lafayette Park a
Nazi flag was seized by authorities at
the scene of the incident nobody was
injured a law enforcement official told
NBC News and the suspect made
threatening statements about the white
house but was quickly detained
and the officials said quote I don't
think there's any place for a Nazi flag
or the statements that he made
so we're being told that a white
supremacist did this
and he had a Nazi flag and in fact
there's a picture going around one that
quickly made the rounds on social media
very quickly and you can see in the
picture the the U-Haul and then there's
a new nice new crisp Nazi flag laid out
on the pavement right next to it so
here's a question is this normal police
procedure like do they normally go to a
crime scene and take out evidence and
lay it on the ground neatly so that
reporters can take pictures
like uh like you know and at the scene
of a crash especially you go into the
vehicle and extract items from it and
lay it all neatly on the ground
not I've never been
you know I'm not a police officer I've
never been do we have that picture there
it is right there yeah
look at that Nazi flag so it was in now
first of all why do you need
a U-Haul that size for a Nazi flag that
size that's the first thing I'm trying
to figure out and the second is that we
assume what happened
there's Miss white supremacist had this
this dastardly plot to kill the
president and the way that he was going
to do it was to take his U-Haul
and slam it into some barriers
that's step one and then step two is a
question mark step three president is
dead uh that didn't work somehow
so they detained him quickly and and
then the police opened up the U-Haul and
they went in there and they took the
Nazi flag out and they just laid it
there on the pavement in the not too
distant past private citizens used to be
largely that private what's changed well
the internet changed changed everything
think about everything you've ever
searched for watched or tweeted on the
internet now imagine all that data being
crawled through collected aggregated by
Third parties into permanent public
records to keep my data private why when
I go online I use expressvpn there are
hundreds of data Brokers out there who
sold business involves buying and
selling your data they don't even have
to tell you who they're selling it to or
get your consent one of these data
points is your IP address data
Harvesters use your IP address to
uniquely identify you and your physical
location but you can mask your IP
address with expressvpn expressvpn
reroutes my connection through encrypted
server that makes it more difficult for
third parties to find me sounds
complicated but really it's pretty
simple you just open the app Tap a
button and you're secure if like me you
believe that your business your data is
your business secure yourself with the
number one rated VPN on the market use
my Link at expressvpn.com mattwall show
to get three extra months free that's
exp
resvpn.com Matt Walsh show as I said not
a police officer I've never been to the
police academy so I don't know what
procedures they teach
cops especially these days but I I
didn't think that that was the procedure
I think that uh if you have a you know a
crime scene you preserve the evidence
um you're not going to lay it all out
neatly and then say hey hey guys you
want pictures of this come and take a
selfie if you want
also um
don't worry about the fact that the
white supremacist name is apparently Psy
varshith kandula
a picture that is allegedly of this guy
is also making the rounds and he indeed
looks like a Psy varsish varshith
candula
it looks like that he doesn't look like
a white supremacist because he's not
white
but I guess that means he does look like
a white supremacist because these days
white supremacists are very often not
white
I mean it seems like the the the
majority of the recent cases of white
supremacists
staging attacks and crimes that sort of
thing we find out that the white
supremacist isn't even White
and so this is another case of that
nothing suspicious about this nothing
strange
take it at face value don't ask any
questions okay in a uh a brown skinned
white supremacist got a massive U-Haul
Van for his brand new Nazi flag and he
put it in the U-Haul and he crashed into
a barrier near the White House
and all of this is normal
okay
you don't need to think about it
read the headline
absorb it move on that's what you're
supposed to do
and how to do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block you become a member today by using
Code wall should check out for two
months for you on all annual plans hope
to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow have a great day Godspeed